hi my name is George Widow and I'm
giving a talk on creating fractal
planets using Wolfram language
I've been using Mathematica since
version 1.1 and I've given a couple
talks before and there we go
I was watching Star Trek 2 as you do
when you have time and I said Jeepers
Creepers can i duplicate the Genesis
planet fly by in Wolfram language and I
said well why not and the abstract
deadline was in July's and I think I'd
have plenty of time to get the whole
thing done didn't quite work out that
way there are several documents that
come with this this notebook is the
abridged 15-minute version there's an
expanded version which has a lot of
explanations which I hope you can take a
look at and two or three data files when
I did this work I was working with the
Mathematica 12.1 beta and it turned out
that there were certain things that were
fixed in 12.1 which were broken in
12-point oh that I relied on so we have
a bit of you know fooling around to get
things to work here anyway there's the
thing I've got Star Trek I want to redo
that and then I looked at in the
interwebs and found these videos by
Lauren carpenter which I have on my
harddrive if anyone is interested in
taking a look at them interviews Lauren
carpenter was worked at Boeing at the
time I believe he was one of the
founders of Pixar and he's a guy that
invented fractal landscapes so here's
the background this is a clip from the
first fractal landscape made in 1980 and
here's a clip from Star Trek - of the
planet flyby and what I wanted to do in
this project was to implement a function
generate these fractal ends
capes and to create a planet which is it
turned out they did not do in the code
for Star Trek and I wanted to make as
much use of the built-in functionality
in willful language at least for the
initial explorations okay the basic
procedure is you start with a set of
points in the old code which I had
written an inflammation implementation
for in the early 80s with my 128k Mac
the grids were kind of fixed so you
started with a fixed grid and started
the corners and you essentially don't
have the step size each time so I wanted
to start with an arbitrary set of points
make it grid connecting them and for
each segment of the grid then pick a new
point halfway in between and repeat
until you have enough polygons to make
something looks convincing the tricky
bits are creating the grid and the code
to select points creating a grid with
arbitrary points is a non-trivial task
so I was looking for something built in
well from language it would take care of
that for me and the new z-values is a
bit of an art edge I turned out was
something I need will still be working
with and I could have worked with flat
maps and this rapped out around the
sphere and that didn't work at all so it
turned out that the best way of
proceeding was to deal with a sphere
directly which means circle coordinates
now I never had circle trigonometry in
high school my father did which worked
out very well for him because he was a
navigator in b-29s in the war and as it
turned out that it was much easier for
them to find pilots than it
to find navigators and there have were
instances of not so swift navigators and
the planes never returned so this was a
really big deal at the time and of
course by the time I was in high school
we had trigonometry but not spherical
trigonometry and I have no idea what
they're doing now but I bet it's less
especially since you don't need to
interpolate you've got a calculator so
you can give you so we'll first go
through the flat landscape and then
we'll go through the essentially the
same procedure again to do a planet on a
sphere just making test data making a
mesh I found this wonderful function
called de l'année mesh which you have
random points and it makes a nice pretty
mesh for you the problem is that if you
give it three dimensional coordinates it
will give you a three-dimensional mesh
there's no way in the built-in function
to say I want to have a two ish
dimensional surface embedded in 3-space
so what I did was I flattened the data
by eliminating the Z coordinate make the
mesh using two aligning mesh extract the
mesh lines using mesh primitives and
then restoring the Z coordinate and in
2d that was pretty good and to make a
new point this is essentially I copied
from the code from the 1980s because I
figured why not segment line you find
the Euclidean distance between the x and
y coordinates pick a random number that
in the range that depends on how big the
segment is and then apply some little
sugar to make it smoother or flatter
bumpier so as it turned out if I use the
including distance between the two
actual points and not the points
projected on the plane the whole thing
blew up so the function that's the
a new point is sensitive to what the
conditions are in this plays out later
so here's the function it takes a list
of data which are the previous set of
triples and returns a new data set which
has the previous set plus the new ones
so the comments work pretty well you
take the Delaney mesh by dropping the
z-coordinate which is the last one get
the mesh lines by taking the mesh
primitives makes the lines from that and
then generate the new point and then add
them together everything's hunky-dory
and I'm not gonna execute any of this
code we can make this a little bigger
but here's a sample grid and that looks
pretty good let's see if we can make
that here I did not try to make this any
fancier than necessary because all I
wanted to do was to see whether the
basic code worked okay
for the planet going to the same thing
except now we need to use spherical
coordinates and I had to look up this is
a copied right from the documentation
because as pointed out in math world
there's no standard way of notating
spherical coordinates some of them have
the r-value first some have them last
some have the theta value from the
middle some have it from the North Pole
is here so this I copied and kept with
me so that I would not make a mistake
when I was doing this work now an
important thing to look at here is as a
theta value which is essentially the
distance from the North Pole the angle
from the North Pole has to be greater
than 0 or less than pi and if that
sounds great if you're using doing
interactive work and you can say well
find if I got the North Pole and I know
what to do if you're doing thousands of
computations that's not working well so
what we ended up doing was to make a
more robust function that wasn't perfect
and it wasn't invertible but it never
failed it always gave a triple of
numbers initial values
turns out or more it's more of an art
than I thought but I just use the
vertices of a buckyball for my work here
making the grid and extracting the lines
does exactly the same thing except we
use convex mesh hole instead of de
l'année de l'année mesh thing with a
convex mesh hole hole is that you don't
get all the points unless it's a sphere
so I did the same trick flatten the
surface to a surface of a sphere get the
primitives and the same song and dance
making a new point I started working all
kinds of fans
and then I remembered remember I haven't
had calculus in 4550 years I remembered
that if you have vectors and there's the
same length then the sum is another
vector which bisects the angle so I have
a really nifty looking rule I should
have made that a prettier size anyway so
to convince myself that my reasoning was
right I made this and okay I forgot
where I was all right so here's
basically the same code for now for
making a new point on the planet same
thing you get you you find the new okay
that's a finding a new point there find
the new radius which is the average of
the values you get the angle between
body of doing the vector sum and you can
see here there's a lot of conversion
back and forth between spherical and
Cartesian coordinates which back in the
dark ages when I was writing was a
really bad thing because trig functions
are notoriously slow fortunately our
hardware's like a million times faster
so we don't have to worry about that so
much
so here's building the planet in one
step
FOMA structurally is exactly the same as
building a landscape except you now
you're using convex whole mesh instead
of lining mesh and you're switching back
and forth between Cartesian and
spherical coordinates so you transform
the data the spiracle coordinates and
then you do jumping back and forth and
this one I would really like to show you
except with 12 point O it fails when you
make try and make enough iterations to
make it look interesting so here's with
one iteration and I loaded in code which
I had saved from 12.1 so this looks you
know decently planet-like
I think okay and this was a primitive
attempt at rendering the surfaces the
way that let's plot 3d does which
doesn't work in spherical coordinates I
found out okay so there we are
and in the expanded note notebook I show
how to take is an interesting section of
the thing you know blow that up flatten
it and then use an approximation to the
plane and then render this stuff so
here's a close-up view of that so in
principle we've done I haven't done the
flyby stuff there's a really nice
Wolfram u course half a half an hour
presentation and a nice notebook on how
to do camera angles and stuff like that
but in principle we're done I would have
been more done except I spent a whole
lot of time trying to make the code work
better so it would be nice if we could
leverage more of Wolfram's
technology for you know relief plot into
you elevation data don't know how well
it's going to pan out the problem that I
had with the initial study was that if
you try to work with a flat planet and
then theorize it you know you end up
with issues at the north of South Pole
and of course you got that seam which
never worked out right so I abandoned
that one of the issues we had with the
random number generator is that the
random seed
doesn't do what you think it does if
you're doing parallel processing and I
always told that if we use compiled
functions that'll work in compiled
functions should make this faster anyway
the issue with this segment length is
something we really need to do and I
would really like to make a flyby the
really big thing was that we should
actually make the proper mesh to begin
with instead of using the Deline Jelani
mesh or the convex ol mesh and i know
that's possible because if you look at
the list plot 3d it's making a mesh on
the fly of crinkly planar surfaces so
it's hidden in there and if if I figure
well form guys can do it I can do it at
least up to a point and if possible to
eliminate the need to be shifting from
spherical to Cartesian coordinates so
I'm going to close up the preamble you
can read that where's my what's the
point why did I do this okay we don't do
a computation to get a number we do it
for insight I don't remember who said
this first but it's all over the place
I was looking to see about learning some
new mass now clearly spherical
coordinates spherical trigonometry is
not new maths but it's new to me and I
really need to understand meshes I found
this book on computational geometry that
talks about that so I got another six
months or a year to work implementation
and the starting points are critical now
the I found an interview that Marcus de
Soto he had with Lauren carpenter about
ten years ago about how he did this
thing initially and he said for his
fractal landscapes
carefully chose the initial points if I
had known that then I wouldn't have just
picking be picking things out at random
and this is even more true I found on
trying to do a whole globe because no
matter what I did do you kind of detect
the traces of a Bucky ball in the back
though the way of selecting new points
is from a mathematical sense a bit of an
art but what you what we really want to
do is we want to have a realistic
landscape and if you look at the fractal
landscapes that are generated you can
buy software that does it I mean you
know if you want something that looks
really pretty don't use Wolfram language
you buy spend the ten bucks and buy the
software is really good at emulating
Alpine scenes and mountains and stuff it
can't render something like the Bryce
Candy Canyon or the Grand Canyon for
that so at some point we're going to
need to make something that deals with
actual geology now you can make a
fractal tree that's very
realistic-looking
and if you allow for the you know
certain randomness and the lengths and
stuff you can you can make stuff looks
right because the model behind the
fractal generator generator is exactly
what real trees use you know trying to
optimize the position of the branches of
the leaves have the maximum sunlight and
stuff geology doesn't work this way if
you think about it the uplift part is
very broadly based I mean if you have a
plate crashing into another one it's
going to be pushing the other one up so
it's going to operate over a wide range
and erosion is local so it's much
smaller range so that's something else
that I intend to be working on simply
because once you start
and it's not so obvious when you're just
doing say a couple square miles or
something a surface or something to fly
your Boeing airplane over which is what
was the genesis of the project 40 years
ago ah but if you want to build an
actual planet you're going to need to
know something about plate tectonics in
geology and know that in the case of
Bryce Canyon for example that different
rocks erode differently so you need to
do that so it's a bigger can of worms
and I think that in rendering that Pixar
uses that get around that by very
carefully choosing their initial points
okay so I owe and the implementation in
the back here you can see everything
that I did all the relevant stuff is
I've already showed you so the other
conclusion is I'd be right I've been
writing code for quite a while and as
Amy Freeman said Wolfram language is
great for doing this kind of exploration
type work I really the the larger
document that I provided is would be a
basis of a like a 40 to 50 minute talk
if I put in all the loose ends and you
know false steps and stuff as I put in
it was like a well would be like a Steve
Steven talk probably a little bit less
interesting but are more illuminating
especially if you're trying to teach a
student or something how to program or
how to discover things about mathematic
or the mathematics of the world it's
much easier to do that than to write
even in a modern language like Python or
Swift where you have to worry about
computer science E stuff all the time
and as now that we have the
WolframAlpha notebook edition we should
probably try to see how it would work in
that okay so that's my talk if anyone's
interested I'm going to be putting
further view versions of this up in the
Wolfram community or publish it to the
web now that we can do that and any
comments or stuff you everyone should
know how to find me because my email
address is all over okay thanks
[Applause]